uh
deandre hopkins clearly gone from
houston and people still want to pin it
on bill o'brien i went back and found
the quotes yesterday from the owner cal
mcnair he signed off on it they didn't
want to pay de'andre hopkins period
and
that's what happens sometimes when you
don't want to pay a guy you know teams
get caught up in this you have a
contract you're under contract for three
more years you must honor your contract
well if the guy's not happy and he's
going to agitate to the point where you
feel like you have to trade him maybe
you should have just paid him and made
him happy it doesn't matter that you
have a contract that gives you favorable
terms your guy has to also be happy and
now chris
he's happy yeah he's in arizona and it's
worked well and the cardinals are six
and three and they're in the hunt to win
the division and tonight's game this is
huge tonight
the winners seven and three and in first
place pending the result of the monday
night football game with the rams and
the buccaneers the losers six and four
and all of a sudden looking at all the
various permutations over the next six
weeks to hope they even get in the
playoffs uh it's it is huge it really is
i mean
big in the nfc west of course
big in the discussion of you know you
know home play-off game whatever i know
there's not a big deal this year as far
as like no fans or whatever but of
course you you want that that ability
and you want to have the highest ranking
possible because in a year like this
who knows how things play out it doesn't
you know you could be the fourth seed
and be
hosting the nfc championship game all
right you can't not this year no not the
four seasons okay one two or three might
one two and three might you could eat
any of those can host it but yes i mean
and these teams are so good and got to
play each other so much here down the
stretch too they're in danger of all
sitting here at six and three six and
three and who knows one of them maybe
not making the playoffs with the way
that their end of the years kind of
shake out here so this is a big football
game and i mean i think it's extra big
for seattle i mean seattle's lost three
out of the last four i mean this is real
this really is they're reeling right now
and it'd be it's gonna be interesting to
see what they do tonight to kind of get
back on track mike what is it going to
be we know the defense has issues you
know i got some ideas on what i'd like
to see more and then offensively
are we going to get carlos hyde back i
know chris carson back but they need a
run miss carson unlikely to play chris
carson unlikely to play with a foot
injury tyler lockett missed a lot of
practice this week with a knee he's
expected to play i think hyde is good to
go
right no chris carson i i would think
just between the things we heard from
pete carroll after the game monday all
those things
you know
talking about russell wilson and all
that i just to me the look looked like
hey russell's great we're gonna let him
cook but you know we're going to give
the appetizer to the running back a
little bit we're not going to let him
cook the whole meal i think he's got to
be going crazy a little bit probably
wants to run the ball i think you're
going to see a little of that tonight
and that to me would be the big thing of
the game if they can't run the ball
they're not going to beat the cardinals
they're not the cardinals have some pass
defense and they got some little set up
of personnel and players that i think
you know like we saw late in that game
when they finally figured out how they
wanted to attack seattle the first time
around
where they have these sets when they get
you in third down there's no linemen on
the field it's all these fast
linebackers you and i have talked about
their secondary is very talented and
vance joseph's been doing some cool
things coaching them to where i think
they'll really give seattle issues if it
just becomes hey let rutz cook we're
going to throw it all game long uh i i
think that'll set them up to lose the
football game if that's the case
advance joseph finally having the time
of his life as the cardinals kicking
coordinator
you didn't get the reference no that was
the first game where they shut down dk
metcalf exactly and and you know in this
chess match
that you've only had a few days to
prepare for it's going to be fascinating
to see whether or not they have plays
where they can get the ball in dk
metcalf's hands does russell wilson
force it into coverage russell wilson
very conscious he has to be yeah the
turnovers in recent weeks definitely
this is a tough one for the seahawks and
they were up big
in the first half of the first game they
were and i think that the model for
tonight it's easier said than done
get an early lead and then grind it
grind it grind it keep calamari on the
sideline i mean that offense has gotten
to the point where the best way to
defend it is keep it off the field chris
definitely and definitely the way the
seahawks are playing you know that that
has to start being a part of their
mantra get the lead and yeah they got to
find some way
to
yeah chew up clock you know and within
that too with the whole dk metcalf thing
and we've talked all that you know hey
they got to find ways to get them the
ball more they just they just do you
know there's not enough for me where i
watch russell wilson as compared to some
other quarterbacks and other great
offenses russell gets no easy
completions you know that's one thing
i'll say you know yeah he's got some
turnovers and they're asking a lot of
them as we know but running back screens
wide receiver screens just i don't even
have to think about it the coach told me
to throw this guy from the game plan and
there it is and there's a lot of other
quarterbacks that get that russell does
not and i think that's an important part
they need to figure out too just to
bring people up into their short passing
game so then they can start bombing
people deep once again
another important point as well and this
goes directly to the guy whose jersey
you're wearing
i don't know how differently we'd feel
about this game if they don't connect on
the hail mary on sunday but they did
yeah and i think that gives the
cardinals the fact that they pulled that
off that gives the organization a
collective
boost
and it also
puts the opponent this week next week in
the week beyond almo not i don't want to
say in awe
but it creates a shine around the
cardinals that i think becomes very real
they're no longer the cardinals no
they're not they are an up-and-coming
oh crap they're going to find a way to
beat his team and i think that mentality
can kind of take over late in the game i
i agree yeah you know they got a coach
that's fearless they got playmakers on
both sides of the ball and as we always
talk about they got a special
quarterback right and when you win some
games and you know you got that kind of
guy everybody in the locker room starts
to think man we can't be beat we'll find
a way to win or be competitive
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports